so last session it seems that we've
managed to have a critical mass of
lightning talks so we will have a
language talk session so it will be
after this talk and then we'll have the
closing and it's over so pick the max or
whatever leftover you have and you're
free to go so next talk an architect to
do the mall by incentive yes and
applause behind please thank you very
much I'm the last one I know if that's
good or bad but good first of all I I
want to say thank you for all the
sponsors our for the organization and
for camp with Madrid thank you and I'm
consensus I'm working simatic partners
which is one of the sponsors but don't
worry gonna be is this not gonna be a
boring talk I just want to talk about
one of the last project that we did it
was well let us start we went to the
client and they told us okay we want to
visualize everything in a dashboard let
me say okay but everything it's a lot I
mean you want to see that kind of stuff
is like something like magic yes
so they told us okay not everything just
the incidence and the incidence could
came from several databases and to tell
you know the the name of the store keys
and architecture to tweet and all so oh
let's do it then all the idea what cc
okay we have to get the tweet do
something with them and visualize them
so I put it in Metro we have a collector
which is going to get the twit we have
another analyzer which is going to do
something with them and we have a
visualizer who's going to visualize them
and the only thing that we have to do is
to connect them easy and that's all
thank you very much rather I kill him I
want to stop here because when I was in
the university they told me when you
find the problem you have to get for I
when you get a problem do you find for
absolution and finally you get the tool
okay in that order problem solution
tools problem solution tools okay not
another order because if you you have a
tool that you love it's like to have a
hammer and every problem is a nail like
so problem solution tools always always
or not okay when when I went to the
client the bread was coming with with
that kind of things we had to use the
spark streaming and e el que a las
except locsta thank you Anna okay well
no logs test we had not going to use it
so the draw is now much better we will
use the Sparky streaming in the
collector to get the twit and we will
use last search thank you wanna to to
visualize them elasticities an indexer
so elasticity is an indexer okay we need
the database okay elasticity is not
already let's just put it on your mind
so in order to get a database i think
that i will choose coach TV why coach TV
because he's no SQL is document-oriented
and we have not used before so we want
to learn more we wanted to use something
new and we saw the ghost TV is good a
wine document-oriented because the
tweets we get the day / the API from
Twitter the tutoring in Jason so we
don't know what the client want so it's
better to take all the tweets to put it
in the database and then we will find
what they want maybe in a second
iteration we could choose a SQL database
but anyway when when we told the client
okay want we want costs three they told
us and watch TV what what what's that
you have only eight face or wife because
they had Clara and that kind of things
both are over hdfs each face hbase is no
SQL esquivel you and it has me use
MapReduce and in the audio in at the
other hand in width height we have SQL
MapReduce and because they are using
Clara we have ambala which is high
because of imbalance k we don't want the
credit for the key value no SQL database
we don't know what we want to query so
we prefer move everything to SQL and
using bah so now code let's go to hive
in order to communicate the idea is when
the collector get the tweets is going to
put it in the database and so how you
going to say to the analyzer okay let's
go analyze it and for that communication
we think that message queuing like
RabbitMQ is a good idea the collector is
going to put the tweet here and is going
to send the ID of the tweet as a message
and the analyzer is going to get Eddie
and do that stuff but we say ok rabbit
they told them they tell us we don't
have rabbit the sky
soap okay it's good to use kefka and now
i'm going to go by one by one one by one
to do the staff the collector collector
has to use parka streaming we found a
cool library which is Twitter spacca
streaming so nice Twitter respects to me
it has to read foundation and put it
into hive do that kind of transformation
is needed and it has to write into Kafka
for the message queuing for all of that
we choose a scallop yeah that's your
face why because we had a team member
who said okay don't worry guys I got
this I can do it in a scholar so it's
okay for me so we say okay do it the
thing is that with this architecture do
don't do not have to have the same
language and in awe level in there all
levels from the architecture you can
change between primary language for the
analyzer it has to translate to locate
it has to calculate the influence it has
to analyze of course i have to do
classification half and put it into json
or some kind of dictionary it has to
listen from from Kafka and it has to
write to the last set and for all of
this we use Python a this morning I
don't know who told us how we are using
a Python three pop three dot 325 we are
using python 2.6 point six okay tell me
what they have so it's something let's
go to put all of this in and a drawing
so oh that's boring it's better with the
actor I put some names for the location
Wally because Wally knows what is
everything the location is going to call
the open street maps api and is going to
get a location of the tweet
he can the translation will use the
Google API and we would leave EPA we
call them Babel because of the top water
bubble for the analysis we use a kitty
kitten why because this this kind of
analysis is about the sentiment of the
twit we want to know if a tweet is
talking good about our client or bad for
the classification a birthday because if
we have a kitten we have to have a
product for the phrase for ways because
for ways now the influence of everybody
okay but what if we want to blow up when
I think in this architecture we always
think in bigger okay like what if we
want to grow we are going to need the
prioritization and for that is good
having a atomic actors ok Atomic mean
that if I have a tweet and pass two
times for whatever reason in one actor
the ratio is going to equal to be the
same ok it doesn't depends of the owners
it should not depends of the others but
anyway just an example imagine that we
will paralyze everything everything the
the analyzer method we have something
like that a lot of process with that
kind of factors we can have a lot of
some problems for example what if that
process fail what if one of this
analyzer process fails does everything
literally in the database ok connect so
all the data is to elasticity and given
and that kind of things I don't think so
and what if it fails here do I have to
do those steps I did it before neither
like it to repeat things but one first
approach was having a field in the
database all the twists has this field
this has finished when for best finish
the this one for bass is going to check
them it's a boolean value to false and
ok it has finished but it doesn't solve
the second question if something fails
did I lost all the all the work
so our approach is doing a consolidation
in the database through the state ok I'm
going to split that concept each actor
with from one state astate one is going
to do something it's everything it's ok
going to the state to something fails go
to astute three here we are going to
stand an understanding whether I have a
badge Annette wit in the state one here
there is an actor this actor is going to
move that way to the state to or the
street state astate three if something
fails when I say fails is imagine that I
have a tweet with the letter A and I'm
trying to translate it you are not able
to change NP is a so that wit is
irrelevant for us we don't want it so it
fails ok so but anyway it goes first for
the state to the next actor is going to
move it to the state forest 85 and yeah
until the end there will be a final
state something like greedy estate and
with that idea in the database we are
going to have a good state Twitter
tweets with good states and bad state
what we can do with that imagine that
something fails here ok this process
just the machine sat down or something
like that and it's broken I have a tweet
with the state to I stopped at the
database we can do something like a
garbage collector looking at the data
with each hour in a batch process
looking for that kind of tweet which are
stopped and put them again to the
pipeline the pipeline is all the actors
together so that's one one thing that
did resolve and of course it resolved a
has finished state we have a have a real
estate so we know when a tweet has
finished or not so again in our solution
we have a row estate for the for the
beginning of the tweet
every tree that goes into the databases
and start with the raw instinct Wally is
going to change the state to locate it
or not located located if we can
navigate it we can not bubble again to
translate not Layton blah blah blah blah
blah until four vez service if don't
know why somehow is not able to
calculate the influence in not going to
calculate in philly i have it will be to
the state now influence and if it cool
it go to the state 3 again one more time
just to keep it on your mind at the
database a wall is going to read from
the state rope you can't too bright we
suppose everything is ok you want to
write in the state located and he's
going to say to the Bible ok this ID of
this to it it's ready for you take it
bubble is going to read it again write
it again read write read write until the
last one for base we're going to write
into the state ready and also you're
going to write into a nettle index it in
the last set I'm going to do one example
complete with everything now so imagine
that we have a tweet the spark is
dreaming in the skull and that stuff get
it he put it in the database he take
daddy put it in the message peewee and
alert get an Orchestrator here is
listening the message key way you
receive the message get baby and say to
Valley ok this ID is for you get it and
do your stuff wall-e gasps tidy to the
right let the read/write read right blah
blah blah blah blah and the 4s and for
best do the last right at the street
really and also for ways say to the
ready org orchestrator ok this tweet is
really like a dictionary or this forest
can go to the last asserts itself with
the best how you want to do that and
they ordinarily the orchestrator in the
it off and finally we visualize it more
or less you get it more or less let's
talk about the visualization well we
have given I don't know if you know
cavanna given is a nice tool in order to
visually see data if you don't know the
data when I want they told us okay you
have to use Guevara I feel like okay I
have no idea what I'm doing but finally
it's user friendly hopefully and you can
back and drove a lot of things and yeah
we got a dashboard it's not the final
dash for its method of caution of the
final version but we have a map the
client wants a map a lot the water map
we have for example all the tweets in a
plot with the influence or the sentiment
if it's positive it is negative it we
don't we don't have ID able to tweet we
have how many tweets have has location
or how many of them and they are retweet
and finally the given allows you to do
some complex visualization about the
sentiment 01 yeah what a moment
yeah thank you well I can continue
without it so lightly nah it's okay so a
having all of these this architecture
what about the conclusion about the
architecture sorry we we solve the
problem that's the main question hey
okay the main idea of this stop is that
a I don't want to show you something new
because I am sure that most of you now
know that kind of things but it's just
to get some ideas then just one of you
say okay it's not the same but I can do
something similar in order to do my own
architecture hope for that but that's
good so we solve the problem and there
is a good point that with that kind of
architecture we can grow we can grow
everywhere I don't know if you remember
the last drawing we can here in this
part we had the collector but but we we
were using Twitter as a input but we can
use another kind of things imagine that
we are doing web when web scraping we
can use a lot of scrapping in order to
put a lot of things or data that we want
to later listen to the message key way
or we can use another API or whatever
you want in whatever language to do that
you are using of the other hand the
actors imagine that the actors are
communicating each other between the
message viewing imagine that each actor
is print days refund database do the
stuff right to the database and when
they say to the next one okay this topic
is really for this the street is really
for you it sent the data to the message
queuing and the other one is
really into one message queuing in
complete liar rabbitmq allows you having
a lot of messes to be with different
topics in that case imagine that we need
more Wallace for example or or or we
need whatever we want we can create more
Wallace in and we can solve that problem
I don't know if I I miss playing very
well but finally and in the last model
that model that was there we send
everything to the last dessert and from
a nasty sir it's called to cabana but a
white cavanna why don't put something
like a jungle for example or something
like doing a special graph with d3 or
whatever we want I mean is just a I
indexer finally what should I improve
here ok the connection of internet
that's the one point now but I will not
use hive I don't I for that kind of
things ok I know it's big data and that
but we are using the free API of Twitter
we have about two thousand tweets per
day it's not big data so i will not use
a chat hdfs i will use something like
Coach three or some no SQL I will not
use Kafka I prefer to you for a
different view because I think that
Kafka is too big for us we are not going
to use everything in Kafka and I will
not use a given up for example I prefer
to do a better dashboard with d3 or some
house on some tool more more better tool
more more strong tool and what we can do
a lot of things I don't know if I'm out
of time but yes so any questions
yeah I finish oh yeah any questions you
can play thank you you can play with a
Venusaur yeah I know but I'm talking so
any question yeah hello thank you for
your talk did you consider using a bad
storm because this is the kind of Apache
storm is the kind of work that i think
is designed to do you have the every
module that what you want to practice is
a bolt you have a source of information
like an alternate source and there's a
sink and it does all the orchestration
of all the services you can decide how
many processes you use on every on a
revolt and things like that and it has
also regarding the problem that you said
about the delivery I need something face
it also it also has some mechanisms to
try to do that acknowledgement of
certain processing and response nodes if
they fail on things like that so I
actually not so much examples they they
have in the web page use the Twitter so
it's in the end a small as what the
design to do this no because of the
client the client tell us okay you have
to use this parka streaming and you have
to use the stool that tools so they
don't have a I'm sorry for sushi to say
that but they didn't have it so we could
not use it we try to manage with that
kind of tools that they give us that's
what we can do but anyway I know is
focused a strong I started sorry and
that could be could be nice in order to
take them all oh thank you another
another question
thanks for the talk you already
mentioned that the reason for not using
given and using something on d3 but I
would like to if you can develop it a
little bit more what they problems your
fountain in Havana the thing is that the
idea of this dashboard is final last
word they want to put in in a television
song theme I don't know where and I
think that given eyes is better if you
play with him I mean Havana allows you
to discover in data so i prefer to using
the tresor III or whatever you want
something more strong in ordering that
we will not able to play with the data
so i don't know if an answer you
questions
hi Thanks congratulations for the talk
Finn also congratulations for being able
to implement the actor modeling in
Python which does not seem a very
natural fit for me it's much force color
for example I would like to ask first if
you have used any tool kit in Python in
order to help you implementing this
pattern the actor model and second if
you have experienced that maybe the
analyzer modules are bottleneck in your
system compared against the performance
of the collector which is implemented in
Scala probably with laka I don't know
this kind of party tree I know I didn't
use any live library something for
whatever for two for two in that model
and the bottleneck i think is they will
be the database because if you want to
loop to put a lot of actors they
everybody has to go to the database
again and again and again and again
that's why one of the reason that we
choose coach to be because coach TV ad
at the rich doesn't stop the database so
that's one idea but about the the
analyzer part we had two models the
analyzer and the classification the
analyzer one this this that was a proof
of ofcom's concept the analyzer part
just was calling to an API meaning cloud
to get the sentiment and the classifier
part was using a secret lair in order to
the classification so they the
bottleneck anything that will be the the
modeling I mean prepare it in that
classification but just going to the
pickles and check them I don't see I
don't think so we didn't test that with
a lot of content I mean I would like to
questions or questions
I I in fact have one if I understood you
for each step of that quality state
machine you sent from one element to one
stage to the following a kind of an ID
of the tweet from me then send a tweet
to the database yes my question is why
don't you just send the tweet okay
because we cool we have to put the twit
in the database yes or yes okay you get
it that's what I'm not getting why you
need to store that way because if we
lose for whatever reason will lose
something we will use the process
imagine that we have a there are five
actors imagine we lose the process in
the third actor that within the database
will be in the first state you will not
do any right to the later is ok if you
send the tweet between them so you have
to write them at each step not if you
call the stage in the message Oh to the
message giver who's the message queue
that's what I don't get yeah that's what
this is a possible solution but the idea
is not only talking about to it okay
that's about to it but what if you use
another kind of a structure that it's
not a ball or is too big to put it like
a really big message I don't think that
this a good idea because I prefer to
consolidate everything in database and
not in the in the message key way then
we we won't agree any final messages
okay so thank you very much I'm sorry
for that so let's thank the speaker
again for this rate oh thank you